well here's something that's kind of sad
but true
the overwhelming majority people may
dislike something but in real life
nothing really changes until powerful
people stand up against it and that's
why this is a significant story country
music star travis tritt has announced he
is cancelling any performance in any
venue that mandates masks requires
coveted vaccinations or pushes
unreasonable coveted testing protocols
why is he doing this travis tritt joins
us now to explain travis trip we're
honored to have you on the show tonight
thanks so much for coming on
and i'm just going to ask you to explain
why you're doing this and let you talk
well
we've done about 75 shows so far this
year all over the country tucker and
uh in spite of the fact that some people
would
try to label these as being quote
unquote super spreaders the actual uh
numbers don't reflect that at all as a
matter of fact quite the opposite in
most of these areas we've seen the uh
covered numbers actually dropped
dramatically over the last few weeks and
months
and so it came as quite a shock to me
and and a lot of my fans
when after the first week of october
during the first week of october
a lot of
these shows
had restrictions placed on them not by
the state not by the
local city government not by the local
health department municipalities but by
the actual
promoters
slash
venue
owners
yes uh and there was nothing that
justified it and so
i i started getting a ton of
messages from fans
who were basically not warned about
these these mandates or restrictions
ahead of time showed up at the gate
and were turned away
and
were not even offered refunds they were
offered
credits to a upcoming show that had to
be used within the next 12 months or
else they lose their money for tickets
and it was just heartbreaking to me
these these people have been shut out
from getting a chance to go see concerts
for
uh over a year and they're finally
getting a chance to do that again and
now they're being turned away for for
some
unexplained reason so this is not about
this is not about following the science
or trying to
look out for the safety of
uh
of of the people there this is about
something else this is trying to divide
people right this is trying to shame
people
this is trying to
basically discriminate against people
that um
they don't feel are uh
clean enough to be a part
of
of enjoying a concert like that
man that's so nicely put
so the question is this you're not the
only touring artist who's experiencing
this but you're the one of the very few
i'm aware of who said anything about it
who said i'm not putting up this i'm not
going along with it
why did you decide not to go along with
this i mean what because you could have
just ignored it like everyone else is
you know i come from a
hard-working middle class family
and i have been extremely blessed i came
from nothing
to have a wonderful wonderful career
that has lasted for
over 35 years in this business
and to see people
that
i know i know these people these are
hard-working
americans
that just want to
take care of their families put food on
the table for their families put a roof
over their head and occasionally go out
and
and
experience a concert
you know enjoy themselves forget about
all their troubles for a little while
and to be able to
enjoy all of those different things
that's that's something that i just
i felt like i had to stand up for
freedom freedom for all of those people
to be able to go out and do what they
enjoy doing and enjoy a concert without
being harassed
man and you were willing to lose money
uh on on that principle yeah credit to
country music i appreciate travis tripp
that was great it was great to see you
thank you very much